you know when i looked at the studies on
ketamine it appeared that um you know
this was like incredibly efficacious uh
very few contraindications to other
medicines and uh and also too it seems
to you know work very very quickly which
is which which is great
um so because of that you know i started
prescribing for for my patients um a lot
of the studies on ketamine will be with
say like iv infusions so the way that i
do it i actually do it um with with
capsules orally
so it's a very very low low dose so you
know with with ketamine i find like
in the classical sense i mean this is
changing now but a lot of people sort of
use it
as almost like a macro dose of like a
psychedelic where like they'll like do
an injection and then they'll sort of
you know kind of get the benefits of
that and then hope that it'll you know
last a long time and for some people you
know they they may just be going through
a difficult period and maybe they just
need that one blast to kind of rip them
out of it and they can kind of you know
get back to normal functioning um but
for other people you know unfortunately
that that just doesn't always always
happen so having like a small amount
that's just like continuous is what i do
so some of my patients will take it uh
once a week some will take it you know
last once a month but i have other
patients that take it you know two or
three times a week just just a low dose
and that seems to be you know incredibly
efficacious overall for for treating
depression
[Music]
welcome to episode 149 of my podcast i'm
mikayla peterson
today's guest is dr mike hart founder of
ready to go medical clinic you might
recognize him from the cannabis debate
joe rogan had on a while back
dr hart is one of the world's foremost
experts on plant-based medicine and the
founder of ready to go medical clinic
we spoke about treating depression with
ketamine treating ptsd with cbd with
dosages
optimizing testosterone and estrogen and
other hormones medical cannabis and the
consequences of the natural hormonal
decline that every one of us is going to
experience at some point
this is a must watch for people
interested in optimizing health i hope
you enjoy this episode there's a lot of
useful counter-intuitive information
here everything we discuss still falls
under the category of drugs so be
careful with the information if you're
severely depressed i still think drastic
dietary intervention is what's needed
low carb can be extremely extremely
helpful my dad tried ketamine and had a
terrible reaction so be careful out
there and do your research before
jumping into anything it can definitely
help some people though
this episode was brought to you by
nordvpn
cyber criminals have very little
incentive to reveal themselves if any
incentive at all even if we completely
avoid fishy links and malware most
websites are full of trackers that
secretly follow you across the internet
that's where nordvpn comes in with
state-of-the-art encryption that keeps
you safe from hackers malware and other
sneaky threats lurking all over the
internet nordvpn also lets you pretend
you live anywhere in the world so you
can access content from whatever country
want to buy new tropics from china
nordvpn traveling but still want to
watch the content you're used to
nordvpn trying to sneak into american
netflix from canada
nordvpn nordvpn never buffers or crashes
with over 5300 servers around the world
which translates into connection speeds
of up to
6730 megabits per second
that's insane take advantage of their
exclusive limited time offer today and
see what full online protection really
feels like grab your nordvpn deal today
over at nordvpn.com
tmpp
or use promo code tmpp the michaela
peterson podcast i hate that acronym for
61 off their premium plan and their free
anti-malware feature all with nordvpn's
30-day money-back guarantee that's only
at nordvpn.com
tmpp
or using the promo code tmpp enjoy this
episode
[Music]
dr mike hart welcome to my podcast
thanks for having me on mikkel really
excited to be here today
i haven't recorded a podcast in maybe
it might have been three months or two
months
really yeah it's a long time for you
it's a really long time for me it's a
really long time for me so i'm glad to
be doing it again
how come you uh you took a little break
i've had i'm okay i think i've told you
this already i moved to nashville and
nashville is destroying my life it is
beautiful the people here are amazing
the music is good
the weather is good and there are trees
everywhere and so i've been like my
asthma is just out of control i haven't
had i the last time i had asthma i think
it was 12 or 13.
so
so that and then all just a ton of work
but
i'm really do like seasonal allergies
kind of thing
yeah i'm allergic to everything like a
diet like anything with fur
except for rabbits okay for some reason
and uh everything like that has pollen
okay
yeah one thing that's really good for um
allergic rhinitis it's natural as a
spirulina which is uh you know just an
over-the-counter natural supplement
there's some pretty good studies on that
that show this is pretty effective in
reducing uh symptoms seems like you
might have experimented with and had a
bad experience
yeah yeah that's so that's the other
thing i also can't take any medication
so i've tried i tried i used to take
spirulina you just take satirizing every
day like double strength cetirizine
every day and that
helped and then and then something
switched when i like cleaned up my diet
and got off of immune suppressants and
now
every type of medication out there just
makes me makes a guy get this like skin
crawly sensation which is really
unpleasant
so
i just suffer so i'm just suffering for
now but anyway i'm fine everything's
good and i don't want to talk about that
so
let's give
the audience a brief background
who are you and what is it you do sure
so uh like i said at the beginning of
the show i'm dr mike carter ridgeland
from
uh st john's newfoundland and i find
your dad actually uh kind of gives a
shout out to newfies all the time
particularly rex murphy they seem like
they're pretty good buddies yeah but um
yeah so i uh i did a degree in
nutritional biochemistry then i went to
medical school and i did family medicine
residency and i've been practicing now
for
uh just over nine years
and uh i have a family practice but i
also do
quite a bit of cannabis medicine and i
prescribe ketamine as well for a lot of
patients and i've been published for
that a couple times also been published
where i work with with cannabis as well
um i wrote a book on
cannabis and uh ptsd called friendly
fire
uh why that's our ditching pills and
lighting enough to treat ptsd uh that's
on amazon and um yeah i mean that's kind
of i guess most of the medical sort of
background about me and i've always been
very very active in terms of my overall
lifestyle so
um you know i keep a very very tight
diet and always like reading the latest
nutrition that kind of that kind of
thing i work out six or seven days a
week uh do a lot of strength training i
do a lot of running and i do a lot of
mma so between those three i'm kind of
doing something every day
okay sounds like my kind of doctor
that's good that's good to hear
uh oh so i guess we should start off
your work with cannabis and ptsd
sure what is it what is it that you've
seen
so um when i basically started uh
becoming a doctor like when i was
officially licensed was 2013 then in
2014 was when this new mmpr program came
into canada and so that basically just
made it a lot easier for
physicians to be able to prescribe
cannabis because the only way before
that was someone called the mmar program
where basically you just
designate someone to grow cannabis for
the patient or the kid or the per the
patient could grow cannabis for
themselves which is obviously a very you
know cumbersome operation i mean that
many people are going to know you know
how to grow cannabis you know how to get
the right stuff kind of thing so um you
know i wasn't really around for that
program uh but the new program you know
it's a lot easier having licensed
producers um you know that are you know
very similar to uh you know
pharmaceutical drug companies and so you
know they're they're you know uh held to
a high standard so it's much easier to
get good quality cannabis and then to
make sure that you know it's high cbd
versus say high thc or if you need
something in between so it just makes it
you know a lot easier
and then
in terms of how i got into cannabis and
in ptsd
so ptsd post-traumatic stress disorder
of people who don't know it's really
really difficult
to treat and uh even now so you know
like a lot of the studies
show that like there's really minimal uh
effectiveness and a lot of uh overall
sort of like mainstream medications so
ssris essentialize those types of
medications
um
and a lot of my patients particularly
veteran patients were saying that they
were just getting a ton of relief with
cannabis
and so um you know when i looked uh into
it you know i find that a lot of
patients that are using thc at nike and
a lot and doesn't always have to be thc
but thc at night can really help reduce
overall nightmares and that's what's
really you know one of the worst
symptoms of ptsd is having nightmares at
night and then not being able to sleep
and then you know as everyone knows
who's listening to this when you don't
sleep like everything just gets you know
so much worse so if you're depressed or
if you're anxious or even you have pain
doesn't even you know need to be related
to mental health and you don't sleep
well often times like that just just you
know exacerbates everything and makes
everything worse
the next day so i found the thc or
combination of seeing cbd to be to be
helpful
for sleep for a lot of patients and then
cbd is really good in the uh in the day
time
and uh the reason being too that that
it's so good for for ptsd patients is
there's one study and i know it is on on
rats but i've seen it in in humans as
well i mean we do need more randomized
control trials on it but um it showed
that it can actually decrease learned
fear and that's what you know ptsd is is
that's learned fear you know so like a
lot of my patients they're afraid to
like go to the grocery store you know
just because like they just find it to
be so stressful and so overwhelming and
like oftentimes they get their food and
they kind of just leave their their food
in the cart and they have to leave okay
did you just find it to be you know so
stressful and instantly overwhelming
it's like no one's like born afraid to
go to the grocery store that's obviously
something that's like a learned so um
you know through using cbd you know you
can't actually decrease that learned
fear response and a lot of patients have
really really benefited from using cbd
in the day time to decrease that learn
fear response decrease or anxiety
decrease social anxiety just kind of get
back from uh to like you know better
overall functioning
interesting okay that's very interesting
um what kind of dose do you generally
recommend for people who are
experiencing let's start with the night
portion if you're trying to if you're
trying to improve your overall quality
of sleep what would you generally
recommend for people who are
experiencing nightmares sure so um if
you have nightmares generally speaking
you do need some thc in order to get in
order to get rid of those nightmares um
you know there are some patients like
say if you're totally naive to canvas
you've never used it some patients can
get a good night's sleep by using just
cbd
but it's really the thc overall that
seems to improve
nightmares so if you're you know just
starting out using um thc usually around
five milligrams of thc five milligrams
of cbd is you know a pretty decent dose
um in order to in order to start the
treatment but oftentimes that dose does
need to be increased um and i always get
patients use a combination of thc and
cbd
the reason being is because thc can be
really helpful for helping people fall
asleep but oftentimes they do wake up if
they don't have cbd on board and so um
it's good to have you know a combination
of both of those cabinets and now
there's actually another cannabinoid
that's also commercially available kind
of called the cbn and cbt has also been
helpful uh to be to has been proven to
be helpful for sleep as well again we
don't have a ton of like like randomized
control trials on this right now
unfortunately
but um you know just through anadola
evans and you know through seeing my
patients you know i can say that there's
definitely an efficacious effect by
using cbn with those other cannabinoids
as well so hopefully that answered uh
most your question
yeah that's interesting i haven't heard
of cbn um do people who use this
combination or thc at night for a long
period of time do they end up having any
withdrawal symptoms if they stop so thc
absolutely can be associated with
withdrawal symptoms and that's why i try
to get patients to use a combination of
thc and cbd um instead of just using you
know pure
thc
and
the reason being again is because cbd
can negate a lot of the negative effects
of the thc
and because of that generally people
find it to be you know much much easier
to say come off of a combination of thc
and cbd as opposed to
say just high thc so you do need to be
you know careful about it and but on
that note too you know there have been
some really good studies that show that
there's virtually no um withdrawal
effects like at all from using fairly
high doses of cbd for a long period of
time um
and then coming off them
completely but you can't say the same
thing about about thc
okay so you have to be careful with that
yeah yeah that's good to know but then
for people who
like i only became aware of
withdrawal from i i have no idea how i
really didn't know i only knew that pain
medication caused withdrawal i knew that
there was alcohol withdrawal i knew
heroin withdrawal which is like kind of
like pain medication withdrawal i had no
idea that there were withdrawals from
basically anything your body can get
acclimatized to which makes sense but
for some reason i'd been taught oh don't
worry if it's you know an ssri or an
antidepressant or even a sleeping pill
it's not like a problem
yeah anything that's like psychoactive
you know can cause some uh dependency
and um you know psychoactive like
sometimes that word um
doesn't get used appropriately because
you know caffeine is psychoactive like
it makes a change in your overall mental
state right so anything that's like
psychoactive can um can can induce you
know some type of uh you know addictive
um potential but we tend to use the word
psychoactive with something that gets
you like high
you know thc um but in fact you know cbd
is in fact psychoactive because it does
change your overall state of being
yeah so anything like that that's that's
like whack that really changes but
something like you know like vitamin d
or something like you know
you know b vitamins like those things
are not psychoactive right so you're not
going to have a withdrawal effect of
course you shouldn't stop taking the
vitamin ds so important uh you know and
it's good to have high levels of b
vitamins as well but they're not
psychoactive substances
as opposed to say like caffeine or thc
or cbd
okay cool that definitely makes sense
um speaking of okay well actually no
let's start with this first say you're
experiencing ptsd during the day like
you use the example
too worried about going into a grocery
store or getting food what kind of
treatment like cbd do you recommend for
those types of people yeah so again i
try to get patients to just use cbd in
the in the day the reason being again
because i'm trying to mitigate you know
dependency on on thc now some patients
if they're in like a really really bad
state
you know they may in fact need a little
bit of thc to get them through that
you know short period of time
but in terms of cbd um i usually start
off with about 10 to 20 milligrams for
patients um and this usually has to be
done two to three times a day so the
half-life is you know kind of all over
the place in the literature but
somewhere between four to eight hours i
find a lot of patients find that it
tends to wear off
somewhere between four to six hours
although you have other people who just
use it once a day and they find it to be
effective
so it really does you know depend upon
the overall individual but generally
speaking about 10 to 20 milligrams two
to three times a day seems to be you
know fairly effective for people for
reducing the overall symptoms but you
know some people need like 50 milligrams
you know some people need um you know
even more like closer to 100 you know
a couple times a day um so it's uh it's
something that
does vary
okay and do you think that's just
differences in brain chemistry the
difference is how they absorb it
differences in brain chemistry also to
just differences in the overall severity
of the of those
you know like some people um you know
you can have a little bit of ptsd or you
can have a lot of ptsd and people have a
lot of ptsd you know they're going to
need a lot more medication than someone
who just has uh you know a little bit
that was crazy i don't think i've talked
about this at all
but when dad got really sick and he was
in a hospital in russia he was in really
bad shape and
i
i've had really bad experiences in
hospitals so before he and my mom got
sick i had
panic attacks going into hospitals so i
never had panic attacks going into
hospitals i got better my autoimmunity
went into remission and then whenever i
went to hospital i'd have a panic attack
and i was like
i'm not someone that that happens to i
don't understand what's going on so
that's kind of where i was and then my
mom got cancer
and i had to go visit her in a hospital
and then my dad got really sick and i
ended up after
after we went to russia i ended up
with
flashbacks
from the hospital in russia
and i was like
huh i'd like i
i guess this is ptsd so i was having
these intensely vivid nightmares where
i'd lay down and i'd have like
extremely vivid nightmares of
these hospitals hospital in russia
and i think that was partly because my
dad was still sick so it's not like it
was something that happened and that was
over it was still continuing uh
and
it definitely interrupted my sleep and i
just kind of like it it went away
eventually it took about a year of
nightmares so i didn't i don't think i
talked about that because it was just i
was like i guess that's just the thing
that happens now but i was like i didn't
realize you could kind of induce it even
if you haven't
you know gone to war or something if you
just traumatize yourself then that can
just happen to you
yeah i know that's that's actually a
very good point um because you know we
do tend to associate ptsd just with
people who have you know been in combat
and in in the military or in the army
but um you know that's that's just not
the case like people who have been in
really bad car accidents you know rape
victims um you know really you know poor
traumatic um childhood experiences like
there's a lot of different things that
can you know bring up uh ptsd symptoms
and they all exhibit you know the same
symptoms so like whether you you know
have ptsd from you know being in
afghanistan and being at war or whether
you have ptsd from you know sexual abuse
from from childhood you know they all
tend to have the same same symptoms so
in the daytime you know the big thing is
hyper vigilance you know kind of like
always like feeling like on edge and a
lot of um you know people that have been
in the army you know they they say you
know they'll be like looking out their
window and that kind of thing because
that's what they're used to they're
they're used to being very very hyper
vigilant um and then at nighttime again
you know they they tend to have
nightmares but again that happens to
someone you know whether they have you
know uh ptsd from you know really poor
traumatic uh childhood experiences uh or
from you know someone who's been in the
army and everything in between like
everyone tends to exhibit very very
similar symptoms overall
do you think what thc does is it just
puts your brain into a state that's
calmer and so it can retrain you it's
like oh no you're not exhibiting this
stress reaction you're calm you're in a
situation but you're calm and then you
just eventually learn your way out of it
there's definitely a little bit to that
a lot of it is really just like
dissociating as well so when you're like
dissociated things tend to like bother
you less and that's the same thing and
and why it treats pain because you know
if you have like knee pain like the pain
you know isn't really coming from your
knee it's there's a signal from your
knee going to your brain that's telling
you that you're in pain and it
interrupts that signal so you're more
like dissociated so you just and it's
it's almost like the same thing as like
when you meditate or if you you are
reading a book or you're really into a
tv show and you're just hyper focused on
that then you're not focused on your
pain or on you know
either mental pain or chronic pain so
it's a it's a it's a distraction and
that's then that distraction can be
very effective for reducing overall
symptoms interesting okay okay next
question then you mentioned vitamin d
uh and i know a lot of people who are
chronically ill actually just a lot of
people are low in vitamin d whether or
not they know it especially in canada
right
how do you recommend like are the
intramuscular injections of vitamin d
are those more effective or less
effective than the oral form what kind
you recommend people take
yeah so i recommend people take the the
oral form
and the amount that i recommend is 500
ius per 25 pounds of body weight and
then to get your levels tested and then
to adjust if necessary so some people
may need more than that like some people
may need up to you know a thousand ius
for for 25 pounds of body weight um you
know i test a lot of people's vitamin d
levels and i have a lot of patients come
in who say you know i'm taking you know
2 000 ius a day but when i test their
levels you know they still come back to
be very very low and that's not every
patient but you know that's that
certainly is probably more than um
than than not and uh and the other thing
too is you do have to take into account
like i said um your overall body weight
you know because it's a fat soluble
vitamin so you know your body weight is
going to be uh you know it's going to be
it's going to affect how much vitamin d
you absorb and how and your overall
levels so you need to
use vitamin d based upon your body
weight so that's why i i recommend
vitamin d based on body weight and not
just let's say like an overall
generalization
huh
and so what do you what do you recommend
for those people who can't get their
numbers up even if they're on high dose
vitamin d um just to keep going sorry i
didn't really answer your question
because you kind of were asking about
the intramuscular i don't have any
experience with that like i've never
given an intramuscular vitamin d
injection before um you know i've
i can't say i've ever really seen
someone you know take uh a ton of oral
vitamin d and and not have their levels
um you know increase as long as they are
taking a sufficient amount um so i don't
know if it's like
you know a necessary intervention for
too many people but i mean if you
used you know oral supplementation and
your you know vitamin d levels didn't
improve then i think that one then would
be a reasonable you know avenue to go to
get your vitamin d levels off but i've
i've never given an intramuscular uh
vitamin d injection and i do find that
you know people can get the appropriate
levels just through oral supplementation
yeah okay that makes sense i have like
my family's just so strange with medical
things that i was put on vitamin d when
i was young when i was very very ill
because the i was deficient with the
autoimmune disorder
and i was taking 10 000 iu a day i did
that for a year
nothing changed
and so then i started with the
intramuscular and those hardly budged it
which makes me think it's
i just don't understand how that's
possible at all
yeah i uh that's a mystery to me as well
uh sorry i can't
i wasn't
much helped you on that one but
something for me to uh to research and
learn about
just i don't know um okay
let's let's switch over you mentioned
ketamine
uh and i know you have a paper written
about ketamine treatment so can you
describe
what that looks like for people i can
just remember i went to this what i now
know was a sketchy high school in
toronto
and i i like most of my
experience watching people on ketamine
was like done in a valley behind the
subway the teenagers on academy not that
was no i was not involved in that but i
definitely saw that
so apparently there's a use for it that
goes beyond ravine sketchiness yeah i uh
i'm gonna answer your question it's more
uncommon like that's the one drug where
i just like i don't understand how
people want to use this recreationally
like it just doesn't seem like it didn't
look
you know it didn't look pretty it was it
wasn't like it didn't look pretty it
like
you know it's not like peop i have no
idea but there's a lot going on at that
school
interesting well lexi you had an
interesting high school i definitely did
it's academy but uh i got into
prescribing ketamine about three years
ago now and uh the reason being is
because you know there's a lot of people
out there uh who do struggle with uh
treatment resistant depression so you
know the
definition of that is that you fail on
two different ssris or two different
kind of classical treatments they might
have even beefed it up to three i'm not
sure exactly but that's the definition
of treatment resistant depression um
and so you know there's a lot of people
that do fit that criteria so i wanted
something else to offer
and uh you know when i looked at the
studies on ketamine it appeared that um
you know this was like incredibly
efficacious uh very few
contraindications to other medicines and
uh and also too it seems to you know
work very very quickly which is which
which is great um so because of that you
know i started prescribing for for my
patients um a lot of the studies on
ketamine will be with say like iv
infusions so the way that i do it i
actually do it um with with capsules
orally
so it's a very very low low dose so you
know with with ketamine i find like
in the classical sense i mean this is
changing now but a lot of people sort of
use it as almost like a macro dose of
like a psychedelic where like they'll
like do an injection and then they'll
sort of you know kind of get the
benefits of that and then hope that
it'll you know last a long time and for
some people you know they they may just
be going through a difficult period and
maybe they just need that one blast to
kind of rip them out of it and they can
kind of you know get back to normal
functioning um but for other people you
know unfortunately that just doesn't
always always happen so having like a
small amount that's just like continuous
is what i do
so some of my patients will take it uh
once a week some will take it you know
last once a month but i have other
patients that take it you know two or
three times a week just just a low dose
um and that seems to be you know
incredibly efficacious overall for for
treating depression and also uh for
treating chronic pain but i would say
more efficacious for um for depression
and mental health and for chronic pain
interesting
okay
and just one more thing on that too i
know i mentioned it briefly but like
ssri selective serotonin we have taken
inhibitors like classically like people
will say you know this is going to take
four to six weeks to work might take
three six months that kind of thing um
which can be very very frustrating
especially if someone you know is like
suicidal you know they need something
right away um you know the ketamine like
i said you know it works generally
within 24 hours or less people generally
tend to notice like a difference in
their overall demeanor
um what neurotransmitters does ketamine
work on it's not because they use it as
tranquilizer surgical right yeah so
that's a good question so it's an nda
receptor antagonist so it has a very
very different mechanism of action than
um than the other medicines and also to
like ketamine often gets uh grouped as a
psychedelic but it technically it's not
a psychedelic now the reason that it
does get groups of psychedelic is
because you know you do get quite
dissociated um it is quite psychoactive
and it does produce you know a lot of
similar beneficial effects of
psychedelics and in terms of improving
overall mental health but you know it it
is actually a a psychedelic um i'm sorry
a uh a uh
anesthetic sorry so that's why um you
know people do get that very very
dissociative um type of feeling when
they use it and also too it does have a
completely different mechanism of action
so all the um classic psychedelics like
psilocybin like they would act on the 5
hd2a receptor so ketamine does something
that's you know completely different
wow
and so does that end up because it works
on nmda versus so it doesn't work on
gaba or serotonin
right
like like indirectly it does but but it
doesn't work specifically on those
receptors
so does that make it less likely to be
dependency forming or for sure
independent i mean absolutely i mean i
you know like a cane you know you can
you still can develop a dependence on
academy but it's very very uh it's it's
i don't have any patients that have
become dependent on it but put it that
way i've been doing it for you know
three years now and people say that when
they stop taking it you know they they
don't get the benefit of the medicine
anymore but they certainly don't feel
like they need ketamine or like or they
need it right now or that they feel
addicted or dependent on it
wow i've never heard of it being taken
by capsule i've just heard about these
like high-dose infusions that cause
hallucinations really for a lot of
people that's interesting i mean it's
it's kind of like you know i guess you
could uh look at the way that i
prescribe ketamine as the way that um
you know people do say microdosing with
psilocybin so
you know it's not in your best interest
to you know take uh you know five grams
you know the terence mckenna heroic dose
of five grams more of psilocybin and you
know um and and think that everything is
just going to be you know okay i mean
you may have a wonderful experience but
you know you may not right but for um
micro dosing you know a lot of people do
tend to do pretty good with that not
everybody but a lot of people do so for
ketamine you know some people you know
may respond very well to that you know
big blast infusion of ketamine but some
people may respond to just a low dose of
ketamine you know a couple times a week
almost was like a microdose
that sounds a lot safer i know a few
people who had absolutely horrifying
experiences with high dose ketamine
so that sounds like a good idea just to
even test out
yeah i think so too i think so too and i
mean my patients have done you know
really really well with it and um you
know it's it's a very safe medicine when
you take it uh you know appropriately
and safely when you use the right dose
um and you know i hope that you know it
becomes a little bit more mainstream
in the future
yeah why do you think it's not that's
really interesting because i can see how
like i know i had ketamine once when i
had um
my hip injected
um when i was a kid they gave an
infusion of ketamine and i was still
awake but i was like calm and i can
remember feeling what it was like and
being like okay
i'm calm right so i can see how micro
dosing that could make somebody calmer
why wouldn't that be more of a
mainstream treatment given the fact that
it doesn't work on neurotransmitters
that are going to cause
severe addiction you know compared to
say gaba or serotonin why isn't it more
mainstream well that's a really good
question i mean my first
thought on that is that you know i think
most of the research on ketamine has
come out in the last 10 or 12 years i
don't think there was as much research
on it done done before
um
so that'd be you know the main reason
why some people just i think are very
uncomfortable with prescribing something
that is a little bit psychoactive and
you do have to be careful about um you
know and when i say psychoactive to me i
know that you know ssris and it's always
psychological so like but psychoactive
and like dissociative you know so some
people are just sort of like
apprehensive about using that and some
people just don't want you know that
kind of big change overall in their and
their in their behavior and their in
their brain you know when they're using
a medicine um but you know
i think that it will change in in the
future and there is a uh a product now
in in the states called escamine that's
been approved that's the intranasal um
i've heard of that yeah yeah yeah so so
i do think that it is becoming more and
more popular now i just think that we
need probably more
physicians to become comfortable and
howling to use it and that i think more
physicians need to be comfortable in
using it as say like a capsule or as
like a micro dose kind of thing like um
like i'm doing as opposed to like you
know this can only be used um with a big
blast of it as an iv where you need
nurses and and you know you need people
to watch your vitals and all that like
you don't need that when you're doing a
very low dose
this episode was sponsored by paleo
valley
collagen is like the glue that holds our
body together it's a non-negotiable run
too low and tiny lines and wrinkles
start popping up everywhere
then everyone knows you're low on
collagen extremely embarrassing paleo
valley's bone broth protein is the best
and tastiest way to get the collagen you
need in your diet the bones are simmered
in filtered water no added chemicals
whatsoever it's pesticide free and made
with 100 grass-fed and finished bones
you can add it smoothies bake dishes
coffee or to just mix it with hot water
and a bit of pepper for a super healthy
snack
i just drink it hot with salt a ton of
salt
some collagen tastes like absolute
garbage so don't just buy any collagen
because some they're absolutely
repulsive this stuff is great it's like
tastes like bone broth that you'd want
to eat their 100 grass-fed beef sticks
are also something to check out if you
need a snack and you're trying to lose
weight not snack on doritos or something
like that i can't eat them because of my
diet that i'm still trying to
try and expand here but but everyone i
know who's tried them loves them if
you're curious to try them yourself i
have good news they're having a sale
right now at paleo valley dot com
just use code mp for 15 off your first
order of paleo valley's amazing bone
broth or beef sticks that's paleo
valley.com code mp for 15 off so how is
it that you're
into all this more alternative medicine
as i'm as an actual doctor you know
you're not a naturopathy an actual
doctor do you ever get concerned that
anyone's going to go after you for yeah
i think you started the first cannabis
clinic yeah so are you worried about
people being even this ketamine
treatment is pretty new so do you have
any anxieties over
being kind of at the forefront i mean
definitely apprehensive and you
definitely have to be very very careful
about prescribing it so you know i have
a pretty detailed um agreement form
between myself and my patients with
regards to you know taking ketamine and
then understanding you know all the
negative effects that
that can be associated with it but um
you know i mean realistically like any
adult right now in canada can go into a
dispensary and buy you know 25 percent
phc and like you know that's gonna cause
a much more psychoactive effect than you
know a low dose of of uh ketamine so you
know i just kind of look at it as like
you know this is something that
um you know it has its risk and it has
its benefits but the way that i'm doing
it you know i'm certainly minimizing all
of um the risk you can't obviously
eliminate it completely but i am you
know maximizing the benefits i think as
well and uh you know i hope that you
know more physicians you know recognize
ketamine as a really good treatment
option for people with mental health
disorders
interesting okay well glad we got that
into the podcast that was interest that
was interesting
um let me see i have a whole bunch of
questions here but i'm going to choose
them
carefully
i'm happy to answer all of them if you
have time okay
let's do this let's do this this is an
area that i
really don't know very much about
because i think i think what i learned
was
anything i had an issue with which was
a lot of things
so it was like oh i'm on a whole bunch
of medications so i'm kind of more
familiar about
what medications are in autoimmunity and
then my mom had cancer and then psych
illnesses so like all that i never
learned about hormone optimization at
all
thank goodness i guess right but can we
get into that a little bit like i know
that you do work on testosterone and
those the hormones interested me more
because that seems like less like a a
drug and more of something to adjust to
bring you back to a baseline yeah what
do you recommend maybe let's start with
what do you recommend people check for
let's start with men what do you
recommend men check for to optimize
their hormones well i think every man
after 40 probably even before 40 should
have
a total testosterone and a free
testosterone test done so it's really
important that you get the free
testosterone test done because
your total testosterone is mostly bound
and because it's bound it's actually not
free it's not available to the tissues
so when you ask your doctor you know to
check your hormones you definitely want
to ask them to not only just get a total
but also get um a free because the free
is going to be the one that's going to
tell you you know how much testosterone
is actually active in your tissues and
it's not bound up
but that's a really good place um
to start you know a uh yeah tsh is
always great too you know uh which tests
for your thyroid
i tend to test for three for a free t3
and a free t4 as well
just to make sure that those hormones
are optimized so those are part of the
um thyroid hormone so generally speaking
the medications given for a thyroid
replacement
is level thyroxine so that's like a pure
t4 and then your t4 does get converted
to t3 so you know a lot of people just
take um t4 itself
but every now and then
you do get a patient who uh you know
doesn't get a good conversion of t4 to
t3 and those and those so for those
patients you may need to use something
called a desiccated thyroid which has a
little bit of t3 in it and then you know
patients can kind of um you know get uh
be treated that way
and then just coming back to the
testosterone so generally speaking i
offer patients a couple different
options the biggest ones are
injections and creams
so when you have the injection um you
know the benefit of that is that you're
only doing it twice a week generally
so you know i shouldn't just mention one
thing on that like on testosterone even
right on the bottle like it'll say
like 200 milligrams every two weeks
which is ridiculous because you know
you're gonna feel like superman for two
or three days
and then it's going to level off in the
last week you're basically going to feel
like [ __ ] so now you really need to
uh try to you know
minimize the the highs and lows
so i find that uh and i find even if
you're given it you know once a week
versus two times a week i mean it's
still it's a lot better but it's still
not perfect so i actually find you know
injecting it twice a week
intramuscularly is is is a good way to
do it um and most patients that
i see will use somewhere between 50 to
70 micrograms of dose so usually between
100 to 140 micrograms a week usually 120
is a really good dose for most men in
terms of
optimizing their testosterones but not
not not uh pushing it like out of range
um but the second option too
with regards to uh treating
is um creams you can get compounded
creams you can get just the like the
generic like andrew gel cream and then
that can be put on daily and so because
it's put on daily then you're getting a
very very even dose um the only thing
with that is that it does have to be put
on daily so people do you know sometimes
forget um the other thing is i mean it's
very very minimal it's overblown like um
for the most part but there is some uh
you know chance that you could transfer
to someone else if you put it on your
arm and then you hug someone else or
that kind of thing so you know i find
that a lot of patients who have like
young kids are really really
apprehensive about using it for that
reason yeah and then just like
yeah yeah and then it's just like
inconvenient if you want to like get a
shower jump into a pool after whatever
you know so um those are generally the
the different options for
um for men
how
frequent like do you all meant does
testosterone lower for all men after 40
or dietary things you can do to increase
it or is it just going to hit everybody
so it definitely starts to decrease um
actually even by like 27 or 28 you'll
start to know it'll start to decrease
slightly and then by 40.
so it's not just women it's not just
winning
not just women but um and i'll get back
to that in a second just on that note
for women uh also have testosterone just
like men do and
that's where a woman's sex drive comes
from as well you know it's from
testosterone and you know i do have some
women who take a low dose of
testosterone not only just for their sex
drive but also just for um their general
energy and motivation and kind of just
sounds kind of fun
it's going to increase yeah make you a
little more argumentative
yeah and probably a little bit just more
like general confidence i guess you
could say and then if you have more
classes it's wonderful you'd probably be
uh you know sounds like you're you're
going to want some
what are the downsides here is my voice
going to lower am i going to get haircut
there definitely are downsides for women
and yeah like those are the the main
things you use you just mentioned you
can have hair growth uh your your voice
can change and then you can have changes
even to your genitalia and the problem
with that is that it can be more like
permanent so like if you um
use like girls like who are really into
bodybuilding but they've used like a
high dose of testosterone like they will
get changes to their genitalia but they
anything with like hair growth things
like that then that generally just you
know goes away as soon as you stop using
it
wow interesting so
i don't want to get into the whole trans
debate too much because i'm going to be
getting into that in an episode
we can
okay okay okay is that what is
testosterone um what they're giving like
girls who want to transition to be
boys is it testosterone so first of all
i'm not like a trans doctor but you know
from my understanding i mean that would
you know obviously be the treatment of
choice is to you know give
you know
a woman who wants to be a man would be
to give her testosterone because there's
no way you'd be able to you know get
like a you know the beard growth and and
just kind of have those general um kind
of masculine features if you if you're
you know didn't have any any
testosterone
so i wonder if you would
that's like i wonder if you give that to
like a a younger girl
would that initially feel good
um like the ted just because you what
you explained was everything in your
life improves but you kind of turn into
a man
so you take it and you're like yeah okay
i feel better
well i mean there's there's risks and
benefits and there's obviously side
effects to everything right so a cane a
lot of people when they do take
initially yes they feel way better and
if they're on the right dose you know
they stay on that dose but if someone's
taking too high the dose of testosterone
like yeah they sure they might have you
know a ton of um self-confidence and a
ton of energy and that kind of thing but
you know they can uh become a little bit
angry or even a little bit more
irritable
so you know you do have to be very very
careful and you want to make sure that
if you you know do hormone replacement
therapy that you see a doctor you get
her your uh your levels checked and that
you dose appropriately
yeah i wasn't trying to turn it into a
hormone replacement therapy
it feels great go ahead do it okay um
thyroid testosterone that's interesting
okay what do you recommend then i'll ask
another question
uh for like the average woman
what kind of panel do you recommend them
running to figure out hormone
optimization okay really good question
so um again uh one thing with with women
and a lot of people don't um you know
recognize this is you want to test all
the different um estrogen hormones so
there's actually three different
estrogen hormones it's not just one it's
like testosterone is testosterone like i
know it through you know testosterone
and free testosterone but that's just a
test it's the same hormone um but for
estrogen you have uh estrone so so like
one estradiol and then you have estriol
so there's three different hormones
so in terms of hormone replacement
therapy
i don't use any estrone because estrone
has very little benefit um and it uh and
it is associated with with cancers when
you look at e2 or estradiol there's an
incredible amount of of benefit um but
there is a you know a little bit
increased risk for for cancers so you
have to be careful with that and then
for s trio it's it's see there's not as
much benefit as the estradiol but it
almost seems to be like protective
against some
some cancers so you know i use only the
e2 and e3 in a specific ratio when i'm
uh prescribing for women and then also
to um you have to get your progesterone
checked because if you take estrogen
without progesterone unopposed
progesterone then so just taking
estrogen you can actually increase your
risk for cancer but if you take e2 and
e3 and then you take um progesterone
then all that risk is basically
minimized and women do like incredibly
incredibly well on it and like there's
nothing you can like like you said
earlier like it is a more natural
treatment like all you're doing is just
putting something back into your body
that was already there before and like
nothing's gonna take away hot flashes
for women for a woman more than say
estrogen replacement therapy hormone
replacement therapy like it's it's it's
incredibly efficacious and and same for
insomnia it's not just the
um you know the hot flashes that keep
women up sometimes they just haven't
selling it in general when they're when
they're going through menopause and that
can be so helpful
being a female is the worst like i see i
can see how i enjoy being a woman that's
not true and we can have babies and
that's awesome but like
i guess that's where the feminists are
coming from that's the better you guys
have the babies
yeah yeah and that's that's pretty cool
so i guess i wouldn't give that away but
i mean menopause seems like a bad deal
um
do anything hormone replacement
therapies give side effects like um
birth control made me completely nuts
so can they have side effects like birth
control absolutely they can all have you
know horrible side effects i mean like i
said you take too much testosterone your
genitalia is gonna grow that's a pretty
bad side effect you're gonna have hair
on your face you're probably not gonna
leave your house right so um you take
too much progesterone sometimes it can
make you way too tired uh you know you
take too much thyroid you can get like
super anxious and that can increase
heart rate and blood pressure it can be
pretty dangerous overall
so you know there's tons of side effects
with with hormones you just need to make
sure that you speak to someone who's you
know fairly experienced with it and um
and who you know knows what they're
doing and and wants to you know do that
that kind of medicine you know it's not
something that you want to just sort of
you know play around with because um
like i said yeah
incredibly beneficial but it can be
incredibly detrimental too
have you noticed dietary changes
changing people's hormones or if you're
low in one okay okay 100
um yeah so if you uh you know if you
have a diet and a lifestyle where you
know you're eating like very few
calories and you know you're doing like
really high intensity cardio all the
time that tends to be associated more
with like lower testosterone but if you
eat it more say like more of a balanced
diet and you go to the gym and you and
you uh do resistance training that's
going to be associated more of like a
higher testosterone level but in terms
of like diet itself um
there's probably other lifestyle factors
that may influence it um your your
hormone levels your testosterone say
more than than others
sleep being a very very big one so if
you sleep poorly that's really
associated with low testosterone so um
that's that's one thing and then also
too there's something called um sex
hormone binding globulin and so just
coming back to the total and free
testosterone so if you have a really
high level of that and then what's going
to happen is that's going to bind all
your testosterone and then you're going
to have low free testosterone and one
thing i've seen one human study anyway
that shows that
um if you do have this issue you take
boron boron can actually lower your your
shgb and then that will in turn increase
your overall free testosterone
so there are definitely some things that
that you can do to
manipulate it um andrew huberman who
you're probably familiar with um he has
a couple supplements that he recommends
um
one of them is uh tonga alley which can
increase overall testosterone
[Music]
that was like a gas i have no idea what
it is is it a mushroom no it's uh it's
some kind of herb um i wouldn't really
know how to classify it more than that
and then the second one that he
recommends i think is um facet x i'm i'm
a lot less familiar with that one but
um the tongue alley like that's in every
kind of like um
natural uh testosterone kind of booster
that you'd see at popeyes or any kind of
like you know health food supplement
sort of store
that's cool
so should people try that type of thing
oh okay wait no cancel that question i'm
not interested in that question anymore
um what happens if you're a young person
and your testosterone is really fine but
you're like hey i've been watching
podcasts and there are all these men on
testosterone and maybe i want a little
bit of extra testosterone
is there anything wrong with that or is
that a bad idea um i don't think it's
like a bad idea to want to optimize your
hormones all i would say is that you
know
what you want to do is you want to
measure it you know and i i know i keep
saying that in this podcast over and
over but like that's the best way to get
things done because if you don't measure
you're basically just kind of like
guessing now when i say that you know
you should sort of intuitively
try to be aware and know you know when
your testosterone is high and when it's
low and i mean i think most people you
know know that like if you don't feel
like having sex ever like you should
kind of say to yourself because it's
kind of weird like something's going on
here um
but you know i don't think that there's
anything wrong like say if you're you
know in your 20s or your 30s and you
know you're feeling that way to get your
levels checked and then to take you know
a more of a of a natural product like
something like tongue down alley and if
it you know boosts you up it makes you
feel a little bit better and you feel
like you're you know your workouts are
better you feel more confident and you
know you feel like you're uh libido is
better you're performing better in bed
or whatever like that and you don't go
for it i mean i i think there's there's
uh there's nothing wrong with that cool
is there a downside if you start taking
it like if you start taking testosterone
when you're young do you have to
continue forever
generally speaking when you take
testosterone um you know people do tend
to take it forever that being said um
like i have guys who say you know i they
say you know i don't want to um
i'm sorry like i want to take
testosterone you know i don't want to
have kids like let's just kind of you
know go ahead and do this and then a
couple years later they say you know
what now i really actually do want to
have kids so you know just something you
can do
so there is and i have a very specific
protocol that i use um and it's just 45
days where i use clomid um hcg and
novadex so three different drugs uh over
45 days it's a specific protocol and
like i've had guys joke that like hey
man very first day i i i got her
pregnant on like the 45th day you know
when this when the cycle is over so you
know there are ways back to
uh to do that and i've had guys too that
are like
they've abused testosterone for like
nine years uh couldn't you know they're
married couldn't get their their wife
pregnant you know which is obviously
horrible uh i've seen them put them on
this regimen and bang they have like two
kids you know so um that's how what is
this
what did you say those medications were
so hcg
um
okay
nolvadex and clomid
okay i haven't heard of any of those
human creonicantotropin
that yeah
yeah that's kind of funny because um
yeah what guys can take it and then they
can take a pregnancy test and be pumped
so it's a good party trick if you're if
you're doing it wow someone on it
you could probably play some pretty some
pretty cool tricks with that
oh that's fun that's the only takeaway
that anyone needs from this episode i
agree
um
can you put people on that protocol who
haven't abused testosterone like is that
useful just for
yeah no it's it can definitely i mean it
would be more considered to be like an
off-label thing but i don't think
there's anything wrong with that like
say if someone
you know is in their 20s or 30s and
they're kind of like down in the dumps
and they say if their testosterone is
like
low normal then maybe that's something
that they could initiate and do like if
they're in like the normal range or high
range like you know it's probably not
going to make much of a difference it
probably wouldn't be a good protocol to
initiate them but like if someone's low
normal and uh and they just want to you
know increase their testosterone i don't
think there's anything wrong with you
know giving that a try
huh interesting okay um maybe last
question then um
how do you feel about hgh
hgh can be super helpful for some people
the only thing with that is that you
know it has the same issue with um as
like testosterone does with like women
like meaning that some of the side
effects yes if you stop hgh it'll stop
like that day or the next day kind of
thing you know it'll be very very short
term but other uh other things like um
like in terms like organ growth like
that's permanent it's like you see these
like massive like bodybuilders on stage
and like why is this guy's like
intestine like protruding out of his
body and it's like it's because like it
doesn't just like increase the size of
like your muscles or increase in size of
like everything so
it can be a really really effective drug
um and like people who are low in in hgh
you know when they take a good dose it
can really make a dramatic like a
dramatic difference in their overall
well-being in their life in terms of
like recovery well-being mood that kind
of thing but again you do have to be
very very careful with it
so hgh grows all your organs so that's
why people have
big stomachs on stage or just like
wow why would you take it then
people know this
i think so i think you know some of
those guys i guess it's it's their job
it's their profession it's their only
means of income so they just kind of
accept the risk i guess um it wouldn't
be a risk that i'll be willing to accept
um and i don't think it's a risk that
they should accept but i guess that's
the logic behind why why they don't
continue to do that
that's crazy can you get can't you uh
raise your hgh levels by fasting
there is some evidence for that like i
don't think it's gonna be like drastic
um but there is some evidence for that i
don't know though if it's like um
[Music]
you know if you could get the same
benefit even just from like caloric
restriction
and uh
like i've done
you know this before where like
intermittent fasting and things like
that and i just did a podcast on this
recently but it seems like
if you
eat the same amount of calories over a
24 hour period or an eight-hour period
um you know overall and i know there's
more to it than just calories but that
is a very important metric but if you
just
like equate the calories whether it's 24
hours or eight hours so you know regular
eating versus time restricted or
intermittent fasting you seem to get the
exact same results
overall
but the thing is is that
if you're someone who you know does
uh much better in that eight hour window
and that gives you the discipline to
like you know naughty right in the
morning and naughty late at night then
you should continue doing that like if
you have something that works and it
works for you like continue to do that
diet but i wouldn't say there's anything
necessarily
like magical about it over say calorie
restriction okay mike uh
you have your own podcast so what is
that called and where can people go to
learn more about you so it's called
heart to heart and it's on spotify you
know stitcher apple youtube uh all
places where where podcasts are
you can you know learn more about me
online
i'm on instagram twitter facebook
linkedin it's all dr mike hart
d-r-m-i-k-e-h-a-r-t and i have a website
mikeheartmv.com you can find out more
about me too
beautiful thank you very much for coming
on well thanks so much for having me it
was a pleasure and uh i hope you have a
wonderful day
thank you you too
[Music]
you